josef maetz willkommen bei einem neuen
video und ich finde das sieht cool aus
da schimmern so nicht dadurch sollte ich
öfters meine videos abends wenn das sind
die autos anfahren
es wäre aufgefallen ob jetzt unwichtig
ist auf jeden fall habe ich auch vor
geraumer zeit weil dieses video gebracht
so beeindruckt du jedes mädchen was bei
der hälfte aller zuschauer irgendwie
nicht ganz so angekommen ist wie es
ankommen sollte es war auf jeden fall
alles ironie ja ich mir gedacht habe ich
will das gegenstück davon auch noch
machen habe ich heute vor das ganze
schon ernst rüberzubringen
also soll halt wirklich ernst gemeint
sei nicht dass das bei der hälfte von
euch wieder anders ankommt als ich
eigentlich meine also was jetzt wäre ich
sage soll auch auf jeden fall stimmen
wir haben der ein oder andere hat jetzt
bestimmt schon raus bekommen worum es
der leute geht und zwar geht es einfach
darum wie man halt jung beeindruckt also
genau das gegenstück von so beeindruckt
du jedes mädchen heute in so beeindruckt
du was jung und noch mal zur info dieses
video ist jetzt wirklich ernst gemeint
jetzt geht's aber los mit dem ersten
punkt und ich bin mal ganz viel spaß
wenn es euch gefällt jedoch hoch oder
jung ja und der erste punkt klingt
vielleicht ein ganz kleines bisschen
komisch auf jeden fall ist es sehr
wichtig auf facebook potsdam oder da
halt wo er mit dem jungen schreibt ein
vernünftiges profil zu haben damit meine
ich jetzt vor allem das profilbild was
bei dem ein oder anderen mädchen mit dem
mich eventuell auf facebook befreundet
da fragt man sich wieso hast du bitte so
ein scheiß profilbild deswegen gibt euch
dabei wenigstens ein bisschen mehr seit
ein bisschen natürlich oder so sondern
sollte das schon gehen also ich weiß
jetzt nicht was dem im wege stehen
könnte so rum
ja als zweiten punkt ist auf jeden fall
ein gutes weiß ich wie ich sagen soll
ich denn es einfach mal image wichtig
und was ich damit meine ist folgendes
selbst wenn euer freundeskreis rein gar
nichts mit diesem jungen zu tun hat mit
dem er gerade schreibt könnte es
trotzdem sein dass wenn ihr halt total
schlecht sah ich mal euch verhaltet so
in beziehung situationen dass diese
diese person das halt sofort erfährt
weil das geht halt immer dann weiß man
gar nicht und dann ist diese person
plötzlich mit dem kumpel von eurem
kumpel befreundet worüber dass man sich
so überträgt das euer kumpel dem kumpel
sagt er mit dem jungen befreundet mit
dem er schreibt dass das mädchen halt
also ihr selber paul wißler
also was ich damit sagen will dass wenn
ihr jeden jungen neben der bei drei
nicht auf dem baum ist das kommt halt
direkt raus dauert vielleicht eine woche
aber dann ist es spätestens passiert
oder seid ihr aber weil es vielleicht ja
diesmal ernst sein soll
solange ich jetzt natürlich weiter mit
punkt 23 das jetzt auch wieder mehr auf
das nicht real sondern so auf diese
schreiben welt sag ich mal
es gibt da nämlich so bestimmte
schreibweisen da denkt man sich bist du
jetzt wirklich so alt wie ich oder bist
du gerade neun geworden was ich damit
meine ist wie kriegst auch selber
ziemlich oft mit wendigkeit auf facebook
nachricht ab und zu streit man dann halt
mal zurück auch wenn ich um ehrlich zu
sein überhaupt keinen bock mehr auf
nachrichten zu antworten von denen ich
weiß dass da einfach nur dieses wg
fragezeichen kommt wm ds oder so eine
kacke ich habe überhaupt keine ahnung
was hat soll aber wenn ihr über 13 seid
dann lass den scheiß bitte weil das
kommt wirklich richtig drüber als wärt
ihr gerade neun geworden wie eben schon
gesagt haben jetzt noch der vierte punkt
und zwar ist es ja so dann kommt es auch
denke ich mal relativ schnell bin auf
beiden seiten interesse besteht zum
ersten treffen auf jeden fall wenn es
dann jetzt wirklich dazu kommen dann
kann ich euch nur eines raten und zwar
seit auf keinen fall schüchtern springt
über ihren schatten und tut so als kennt
ihr diese person schon euer leben
langsam mal und seid genauso mit ihr wie
mit ihrer besten freundin weil wenn ihr
überhaupt gar nichts sagt und der junge
eigentlich alles sagen muss und wir dann
immer nur ganz kurz auf diese fragen nie
erstellt oder so antwortet dann denkt er
sich auch toll wenn ich mit mir redest
können was auch gleich sein lassen ja
leute ich habe dieses video ist auf
jeden fall auch gemacht weil ich
andauernd nach hinkriege ja kannst du
mal sagen wie das so bei jungs abdruck
was muss ich tun damit er mich toll
findet und so und ja das freizeit mal so
die antwort auf diese ganzen fragen
nicht dazu
auf jeden fall hoffe es hat euch
gefallen falls ja dann würde ich mich
auf jeden fall übernommen nach oben
freuen ansonsten ist hier instagram ein
gewinne twitter heißt ich genauso können
ja beides mal abschicken link auch in
der video beschreibung und ich auf der
linken seite geht's weiter mit meinem
letzten video das war mit meiner
freundin da habe ich ein paar fragen
antwortet und hier auf der anderen seite
ist dass er so beeindruckt du jedes
mädchen video da könnte ja mal drauf
gehen und wie gesagt das ist da alles
nicht ernst gemeint und die ganzen
kommentare die sagen was klar was du da
das kann ich auf keinen fall verfolgen
schreibt einmal alles ironie und mit
freude auf jeden fall sehen man sonst
nichts